foreign
is from Kelly in Union Maine
hi this is Kelly from Union Maine my
husband is being tested for sleep apnea
and he's wondering if there's anything
besides the CPAP machine that would be
helpful he is 64. he's in good health
he's not overweight he just struggles
with sleep and snores a lot and that's
why he's being tested all right so Jack
I want to run these by you so earlier I
talked about the five things that most
improve my wife's and my sleep we went
through the grounding mat lots of
sunlight especially in the morning to
reset the Circadian rhythm the Sleep
Master sleep mask is a total Game
Changer uh the one thing I forgot to
mention was the earpiece we we use it's
called earpiece p-e-a-c-e it's earplugs
basically and the brand that I use that
works best for me is a brand called
earpiece not a sponsor advertisements
suck and so but I'm telling you that
those block out any other noise that
might be bothering me especially crucial
if you live in a city or somewhere and
you're an apartment building there's
going to be some other noise somewhere
and then also having a nice pillow but
beyond that I have a dozen other things
that I've done to improve my sleep one
is a firm mattress I have a bad back and
so a firmer mattress works really well I
I happen to have one of your mattresses
Jack which I paid for it's not it was
like he didn't give me a mattress to be
on the podcast but uh you make really
nice mattresses and you have you know
you customize it to the needs of someone
can you talk about maybe how a firm
mattress versus a really cushy mattress
makes a difference for different people
so it that that's the word firm is a
little bit of a misconception that's
kind of the dated thing where a firm is
better and it really is two things one
is density is really important okay
um the difference between firm and
density is you you want Contour you
wanted to be able to adapt to your
curves to your spinal curves and uh but
you need that to be a very dense
material so that it's constantly giving
you support and it's not breaking down
easily over over time the second thing
whether it's firm or or soft in in a
general feel depends on your spinal type
so if your posture is if you have a
flatter lower back you need to have some
a mattress that you don't sink into as
much if you've got a very pronounced
lower back arch you actually need to get
deeper into that bed so conventionally
people are getting into soft Beds which
are low density
um and because that's what they need for
their comfort but they're not getting
the support that they need but
ultimately the more curves you have on
your back you need to get sleep in a bed
and the flatter your back you need to
sleep on a bed that initial surface
needs to needs to be contouring into
that so the the product that you're
sleeping on is designed for flat flatter
back but yet you do feel that initial
Comfort it's not it's not a hard bed
it's really it really is adapting to
your body extremely supportive and
because it's so dense it'll do that for
a really really long time that makes
sense because you got a few spine yeah
yeah so I mean it would make sense that
you needed a little bit more of a more
density my L5 and S1 are fused together
okay and naturally I broke my back when
I was a teen and it sort of just grew
together and uh that makes sense so
instead of saying firm maybe it's more
supportive is the way to think about
that more dense well here's here's the
here's the trick that's where when we
get into soft beds well sort of at
essential we don't make low density beds
right our our softer beds are higher
density than our and that's kind of like
people have have how do you have high
density and not be firm but density is
just a concentration of product it
doesn't doesn't change so we increase
elasticity and increase density so you
have it's basically a rubber we've
formulated a rubber that adapts and
Contours your body but is is
quite firm and dense in in in in in in
in its support that makes a lot of sense
I'm going to go through this list Ryan
you tell me if any of these things are
applicable to you so blackout curtains
especially if you live in a city yeah I
don't have them in my new house because
we live in the middle of nowhere and
there just aren't there isn't a bunch of
light coming in and I have a sleep mask
and it's fine but when I lived in the
city here blackout curtains 100 game
changes if I can interrupt you just
sorry about that about that but you're
being selfish with the sleep mask
blackout curtains takes care of you and
your wife right exactly exactly so my
wife uses the same the same sleep mask
and we have no curtains because we walk
on the Peeping Toms dude we lived in a
loft in Hollywood which now as I'm
saying that sounds so pretentious man
but anyway
um so much light like you've been there
you know it's not pretentious right
but like it was so much light that we
had to do the sleep mask and there was
no chance of like doing like blackout
things but I'll tell you like just
leaving that apartment uh my sleep
increased my wife also uses a white
noise machine at night which doesn't
really help me but for her the one she
uses I wrote it down here marpac Dome
classic white noise machine we'll put a
link to that in the show notes but it
has an actual fan in it so it's not
digital it's an analog white noise
machine and that for whatever reason it
lulls her to sleep and she leaves it on
all night and uh it works really really
well for her especially in conjunction
with the earplugs that she has we got
the air filters running all the time
that definitely helps me go to sleep
like if it's not on I'm like something's
wrong yeah something's off right right
and for me it doesn't it doesn't really
matter but for her it makes a big
difference and so that's another way to
support her is finding out what helps
her sleep better and that's going to
also help me sleep better as well really
quickly Jack would you say there's a big
difference between like a digital white
noise machine like a digital app that
gives white noise versus a machine shop
I mean as far as to your mind there
wouldn't be a there wouldn't be a
difference however you're introducing
again more digital more Electronics
but they're to the brain it's whatever
works work so whether some people it's
music it doesn't have to be white no so
some people are actually just appreciate
having music and these are all
stimulants and we focus so much on that
in in what we study on what makes you uh
uh sleep well what keeps you because
here what we're trying to do is keep
people in deep sleep and REM sleep
longer that's that's a secret whether
you're sleeping five hours a night or
eight hours a night if you're getting
your two and a half three hours of deep
and REM sleep you're you'll be great
either way Bingo a few more things I
know Professor Sean is going to uh get
me ding me on time so I'm gonna try and
get through as many of these as possible
here no Wi-Fi at night we turn the Wi-Fi
router off or now we don't even have
internet at home because uh my wife she
found out she had some crazy reaction we
slept next to a Wi-Fi router one night
at her parents house in Minnesota and
she couldn't sleep all night and then
realized like she was right next to a
Wi-Fi router turned it off the next
night no problem and from then on has
realized that even if you have a Wi-Fi
router in your house it turned that off
at night it's harder if you live in an
apartment building your neighbor could
have one next to your head but having
that Wi-Fi off really helps her it makes
less of a difference to me but I know
with her it's uh it is a total Game
Changer uh blue light again doesn't make
a huge difference to me but blue light
before bed last two hours before bed my
wife even wears those blue blocking
glasses at night yeah in case we have
any sort of you know blue light coming
in from a glowing screen or from the
overhead LEDs or incandescent lights
which we're going to argue about later
malabama
and and so removing that blue light
helps your circadian rhythm helps you go
back to sleep yeah absolutely and and
those glasses are fantastic they have
daytime blocking glasses and then they
have the the the
darker pre-sleep ones so if you look at
brands that are really getting deep into
that they'll have two versions of a
light block glasses so for for work and
and just eliminate that or artificial
life throughout the day which kind of
which helps at night but they have some
that are really make it that much more
difficult in fact to to work watch TV
and you and you can you can see the
screen and all that but I mean that
onset of sleep starts to kick in and you
you gladly shut things down go to sleep
so I think that those are fantastic to
get to wearing those glasses two hours
before
um or just avoiding the light altogether
if you can if you can but that's that
that's that's tougher today's world
right and and but if you get those
glasses on you're kind of conditioning
yourself and and forcing yourself down
that path uh what we've seen with with a
lot of athletes that we've worked with
no one wants to shut off their Wi-Fi no
one wants to really go down that path of
giving up all of their toys and all of
their Communications and that's where we
we really uh turn to the quantum energy
and that made a huge difference on
eliminating the impacts and the
stimulants from Wi-Fi the EMF blocking
that you put into your mattresses that
makes a lot of sense let's go through a
few more things here real quick because
what I found is that subtraction is
greater than addition so by adding all
these gadgets like earplugs and face
masks and blue blocking glasses we don't
need all of these accoutrements quite
often we can remove certain things that
are disturbing our sleep and so the next
few things I have on the list here we
have no alcohol no coffee afternoon or
no coffee at all my wife just doesn't
drink caffeine anymore because it
disturbs her sleep even if she drinks it
at 10 AM she notices it later that night
she's more sensitive she metabolizes it
really slowly I'm metabolize it quickly
so I can have coffee a few hours before
bed it's not a problem for me but for
her it totally wrecks her no alcohol
she's removed alcohol from her life
almost 100 percent that's true
tremendously help also no THC so that
tends to wreck her deep sleep and so
just finding out you know what works for
you what doesn't work that's removing
these things that are disturbing sleep
also eating before bed is a No-No in our
household because it disturbs your sleep
so if you eat a meal within three hours
of going to bed it you end up tossing
and turning absolutely eating late is a
is a big problem yeah and then uh one
thing I do do before bed is I'll have a
spoon of Honey often Manuka Honey right
before bed the carbohydrates tend to for
whatever reason stimulate my deep sleep
in a way not a full meal but just a one
teaspoon of honey that seems to to help
out a lot and then if I'm struggling
ever in the middle of night I tend to
wake up pretty early in the mornings if
I want to get more sleep there's an app
that I'll turn on it's called indel
e-n-d-e-l there are other ones out there
as well brain FM the Aura app actually
has different sleep and what it is is
it's um it's listening to soothing music
that soothes you back to sleep any
feedback on any of those Jay
well the whole thing is uh depending on
being at rest or being in deep sleep so
once you're awake in the morning and
you're just resting you're not
necessarily getting that uh the recovery
that you're looking for the cellular
recovery that's only happening in your
deep sleep cycles right uh so that
that's that's more about eliminating you
know some of that uh uh fatigue that you
want to have but again all through REM
and deep sleep is where that fatigue is
is primarily limited and so the morning
stuff I haven't seen any evidence of uh
being rested once you're awake having a
real impact on on the body in your life
but that makes sense I haven't had that
much studies on morning apps uh
everything before sleep and actually all
of daytime uh eliminating caffeine
eliminating any foods consumption uh in
those last three hours are are critical
eliminating light all these are are all
the stimulants that uh that have one
thing you do need to add which people do
forget you need to add training you need
to work out because
um during the daytime you need to be
um you need to be working out you need
to be working your muscles because the
body recognizes when it's when it's
training and when it's at rest yes and
if you're if you're 24 hours is pretty
identical sitting at a desk or laying in
bed uh the body has a harder time
differentiating the two can I Circle
this back to the sleep apnea thing yeah
so the CPAP this is something that I've
been avoiding because I feel like I need
to CPAP I have I do all these things and
my sleep does get better but I still can
improve it is there is there any
substitution for a CPAP if someone has
sleep apnea well I'll tell you one
simple trick okay and it it won't work
for everyone but I'll tell you if it
works
and one simple trick to avoid the CPAP
machine yes Jack we are all ears man so
if you can incline your bed as slight
slope okay uh simply putting some three
inch blocks at the headboard okay and
and sleep at a slight angle just with
your head up with your head up okay so
you don't need to have an adjustable bed
this is really simple easy couple of two
by fours trim them up and and just get
that angle going and that angle again is
similar to what an adjustable bed does
yeah but we technically all should be
sleeping at a slight angle so if you
have the sleep apnea that's something
that is is typically closing up your
your throat that slight angle will help
out uh may not work for everyone but if
it does that's really easy it's
something to try first before yeah
exactly okay Josh I also have some uh I
mean Ryan I also have some crystals I
can sell you you just put them under
your thumb
you have no idea in them every morning I
like roll over and like I go to hug and
kiss them right before I get out of bed
because I typically get out of bed
before her and I'll put my arm
underneath her pillow and literally like
I'm knocking crystals all over the floor
I'm like why are these crystals
everywhere the last thing I'll say for
Kelly's question because I know we are
way way over but it is what Ryan said
earlier I try some of these things but
when we're not trying them with
discipline what often happens is oh yeah
you know what I didn't drink for one day
and it didn't it didn't solve all my
sleep problems I guess I'll go back to
drinking or oh you know what I gave up
weed for three days I guess uh didn't
fix everything about my sleep deficit
and I guess I'll go back to it I'll go
I'll go back to these habits that are
impairing my sleep but if you find that
you do go three to six months without
these things all of a sudden the sleep
does begin and maybe you won't need the
the CPAP machine at all but it's
probably not going to happen overnight
in the words of Mr Miyagi there is no
try only do
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free three